what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today we got a new little trailer from
imax and it actually has a lot of new
footage and new dialogue especially
coming from electro more than just
you're not gonna take this away from me
which is all we've heard him say so far
as you'll see this is kind of a villain
trailer it says spider-man's greatest
villains have been unleashed but one
very very important part of this trailer
is that it actually confirms some leaks
that we got a while ago and a lot of
people are claiming that there could be
another spider-man in this trailer that
is not tom holland spider-man a
spider-man on the statue of liberty
scaffolding has been spotted but when
you zoom in it's not too clear is this
just tom or could it perhaps be a
different spider-man and could this be
another editing mistake by sony and
marvel but i'll show it to you and let
you decide for yourself also tom holland
zendaya and jacob batalon have done a
promotion for spider monday which is
only a couple of days away and we're
going to talk about if there could be a
lot more footage coming on cyber spider
monday but first thank you so much to
surf shark for sponsoring this video
guys you know i'm a huge fan of vpns
especially when it comes to watching my
tv shows and of course security i use
surfsharkvpn to watch netflix shows that
aren't available in my country and i
also use it when i travel so i can
continue to watch the same tv shows no
matter where i am in the world
surfsharkvpn helps you change your
virtual location so you can access and
unblock content libraries and streaming
services from other countries we have
the hawkeye series coming up on disney
plus and if you don't get that in your
country surfsharkvpn is the solution for
you i also use surfsharkvpn to keep my
data safe i do a lot with my computer
and my network with youtube the last
thing that i want is my information
getting out there to somebody surprise
vpn encrypts your online data and helps
to secure your personal information when
using free public wi-fi it also masks
your ip address so you become private
online and the best part is if you click
the link below and use code cosmic
surfshark.com you can get 83 off surf
shark and a extra four months for free
so check out this imax trailer if you
haven't yet and pay very close attention
to it
look at this place
and all the possibilities
hello peter do i know you
it's december they're a danger to our
universe spider-man's greatest enemies
are unleashed
in
i'll fix imax
spider-man no way home experience it in
imax coming soon there are a few things
that we see here one is that we see new
shots of jamie foxx's electro we also
have new dialogue from him so let's
start off by talking about that jamie
foxx's electro says look at this place
and all the possibilities now obviously
he is in a new universe the last time we
saw him he died at least he seemingly
died some people argued that he could
have been transported or teleported
somewhere at the end but i'm pretty sure
he died especially since one of the
trailer says they all die at the hands
of spider-man so when he says look at
this place he's talking about the new
universe the new new york in new york
where the avengers now exist or what's
left with them or the new avengers a
place where stark industry exists and we
know that he's gonna get a stark reactor
somehow and that could have something to
do with what he is wearing now when i
said there was an important leak that
was confirmed this is kind of what i was
talking about because a long time ago we
got a bunch of leaked pictures of some
villains that were believed to be fake
but now it's confirmed that they are
real because in those leaked photos
jamie foxx was wearing this kind of
construction worker uniform the same
exact one we see here where jamie foxx's
electro was talking to somebody kind of
behind curtains or bars here i'm betting
that it's bars he's wearing this kind of
yellow jacket and it's the same one that
we saw in the leaked photos now this
means the other leaked photos that we
saw of willem dafoe and doc ock were
real and this also gives us further
evidence that some leaked photos that
came out with andrew garfield and toby
maguire are also probably real because
so far all the photos that kind of came
out and were leaked around this time
have seemed to be proved legitimate
there was also a scene with all the
villains inside of all of their cages
inside of doctor strange's sanctum these
photos are seemingly real as well
because once again they showed jamie
foxx wearing this coat and now we've
seen doc ock in one of those prison
cells in the sanctum as well so
everything's looking to be pretty true
here so for the people who are doubting
that toby and andrew are in the movie i
get it but there's so much evidence now
and we'll talk about even more in just a
bit but let's talk about a brief new
scene with doc ock and peter brief new
footage of doc ock throwing cars at
spider-man now when the promotional
photos from empire and entertainment
weekly when they were all released of
course they all had pictures of this
scene and this famous bridge now for a
while we were wondering what exactly was
peter running away from and here i think
he is actually saving some of the cars
we can see doc ock is throwing cars
around and it's possible that they could
have people inside them or they could be
going to hit people a lot of people were
kind of giving the movie crap because
they were like oh spider-man's running
away from doggock he's scared but i
definitely don't think that's the issue
here i don't think tom holland
spider-man is running away i think he's
probably trying to save people or use
the cars in some way against doc ock and
we get a brief new clip of him kind of
wrapping him up in his arms bringing him
towards him we've seen this a little bit
it's just a slightly bit of extended
footage which seems to be what these tv
spots are doing and side note for the
people saying that they're showing too
much they're really only showing a few
scenes you gotta keep in mind it's a two
and a half hour movie a little bit over
two and a half hours and all in all
they've probably showed us three minutes
and 30 seconds of footage from the movie
and these tv spots just add a slightly
bit of new footage each time so don't
worry they're not spoiling the entire
movie the leaks are really what has
given the movie away but hey we like to
talk about leaks we have talked about
toby maguire spider-man and andrew
garfield spider-man showing up in
spider-man knowing home for a very long
time and speaking of that there is a
very interesting part of this tv spot
here that shows a spider-man and i say
that very intentionally on the
scaffolding on the statue of liberty now
there's been a lot of debate online
right now on who this spider-man could
actually be some people say hey that's
toby some people say that's andrew now
this really is a blink and you'll miss
it type of moment especially if you
don't know what you're actually looking
for i didn't see any spider-man there
the first time either and after looking
at it now it is extremely hard to make
out you still can't really see a clear
face but what i do see is this
spider-man is holding what looks to be
that cube that doctor strange had now
this is a pretty big giveaway
unfortunately that this is tom holland
spider-man because we have actually seen
him in this scene on the statue of
liberty scene holding the box this cube
that doctor strange was seemingly using
to send all of the villains back to
their own respective universes this cube
is kind of the key to everything here to
sending everybody back to their
universes but also keeping our universe
kind of stable we've seen the end of the
main trailer where dr strange says
they're coming through and i can't stop
them now what is coming through well it
could be other universes it could be
other villains we do know that
spider-man no way home leads up into
multiverse of madness where everything's
gonna be into madness so the chances
that some universes start to collide at
the end of spider-man no way home is
actually pretty high now could this be
another spider-man sure the editing of
marvel has been very clever over the
years and even though we've seen tom
hall and spider-man holding that cube
that doesn't mean that another
spider-man can't be holding the cube as
well after all they're all going to be
working together and we've already seen
some pretty clear evidence that the
other two spider-man are in this movie
and have been edited out of some scenes
in the trailer but i still do think that
this is probably tom hall and spider-man
i don't think they'll show the other two
spider-man before the movie comes out
but could they be teased perhaps in a tv
spot or if there is a final trailer yes
yes they could be teased in fact they
have already pretty much been teased
especially some of the lines from doc
ock so could that happen in a final
trailer a final tv spot yeah good and in
fact today tom holland jacob babylon and
zendaya did a promo for sony reminding
people about spider monday and when
tickets go on sale that day now they
didn't say that any new footage or
anything was going to be released but
i'm willing to bet that there is i mean
we're basically getting a tv spot every
day now every other day they all include
a little bit of new footage and since
they are actually promoting the day i'm
willing to bet that we get something
maybe a clip on good morning america
maybe just a clip on youtube a new tv
spot something and hopefully whatever
comes out gives us just a little bit
more than we've gotten so far i would
like a tease of the other two spidermen
i wouldn't like to see them but i
wouldn't mind seeing two shadows or
possibly hearing some theme music and if
there is indeed going to be another
final trailer which we are unsure about
right now i wouldn't mind seeing that
tease in that final trailer but in the
meantime let me know what you think
about this new imax trailer spot and let
me know which spider-man you think that
is on the statue of liberty there also
don't forget to subscribe to stay up to
date on the mcu and i'm still doing my
spider-man collectible giveaway all you
got to do to enter subscribe to my
channel and cosmic culture and leave
some comments on some recent videos for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram twitter and tick tock and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof